What we were seeing from the rand,
it was at its best levels of 2024.
And actually the drop that we saw on Wednesday
had halted a three day rally for the rand.
And as you mentioned,
this is really coming after this opinion poll that is showing that
potentially the ANC is not going to get this 50% majority
that we've been talking about for the past few weeks,
but is actually going to drop below 50%,
which for many investors, this just continues to spell more uncertainty
because then what does that actually look like?
That would mean potentially
we are gearing up for a coalition government.
And you know,
it really depends on which parties that you're talking about
what that could mean for investors.
And so, you know,
we're seeing the ran right now,
if you take a look at that chart pulling back just a bit slightly,
but it just spells even more uncertainty.
And we got a little bit of that even when we spoke with E F
F party leader.
The E F F is one of the biggest parties here in South Africa.
It is LED by, his name is Julius Malema.
He is a very bombastic, a charismatic person,
but he was even saying his expectation
and his polls are showing that the ANC will likely not get 40%.
And so really, investors are paying close attention to what this means
for the May 29th election.
And Jen, you spoke with the leader
Of the E F F party yesterday
talk to us about his view about his chances in the election.
Yeah, I think it's important to put into context who Julius Malema is.
Uh, he used to work, uh,
he used to be the ANC youth leader.
So he worked very closely with former president Jacob Zuma, uh,
and really
has just gained more and more popularity over the past few years
as the E F
F party leader. And as I mentioned,
it's one of the main parties that is contesting in this election.
And listen to what he told us about his former boss
who is now able to run in this election. Take a listen.
Our base has never been based on the basis of the love and support, er,
for Jacob Zuma. So why would, er,
something that was not based on his love and support be threatened, er,
by him? We are a national organisation.
We have had successful release in all, uh,
provinces and we are the only organisation, uh,
after the a N C that has got membership
and presence in almost all municipalities in South Africa
and exist in every corner of South Africa.
We welcome President Zuma to the terrain, er,
let him come, er,
but he knows himself by now that is not easy to form a political party.
Yeah, so that was just a part of what Julius Malema was telling us.
And I think it's important to note, uh,
for investors, Uh,
we've, we've done a few polls here internally, uh,
and shown that investors are very weary about a potential e F, f,
a N, c, uh, coalition,
the E F, F,
just for some context,
as well as has been for land expropriation without compensation.
They want to nationalize the mines and also the Reserve Bank.
And so
this is a party that has really gained a lot of popularity here
in this country. And the question is,
what does it look like going forward?
What does a potential coalition that look like, uh,
with some of these parties? Could he.